I called the thing that got rid of the
passion parachute disappeared I started
falling 1986 I was training for one of
our balloon adventures and because the
bloom is going to fly it 35,000 feet if
something catastrophic Lee went wrong at
35,000 feet you can't just jump out and
pull a parachute because you'll be the
airs too thin it would grip the
parachute off so you had to learn learn
to skydive I'm Dyslexic so I can make
horrible mistakes on occasions anyway so
we went out in the plane and they said
Richard look you know you've got a
reputation of you know being an
adventurer we're not gonna tendon that
jump you you're gonna go on your own so
the next moment the door opens and I'm
throwing myself out of the plane very
unnatural thing to do the first time
there was a instructor of my right and
there's an instructor of my left and
I've sort of moved my hand down to to
show them where I was going to pull the
parachute and one of them the one on my
right was going now
and the one on my left was going yeah
and didn't see where my hand was going
and then on the third occasion like went
down like the guy on my left and I
pulled and I pulled the thing that got
rid of the person who actually
disappeared I started falling well
fortunately the guy that could see what
I was about to do wrong managed to grab
my spare Deaver and mice and open my
parachute as I was plummeting and I
landed on the ground feeling this lay
lay there on the on the on the field
thinking how much
you